Islam does not believe in freedom of
speech. Islam does not believe in
freedom of religion. And Islam does not
believe in separation of mosque and
state. Those three things.
>> So that was uh Charlie Kirk
and uh he was killed yesterday
and uh let me make something very clear.
We do condemn what took place, what
happened to him because doesn't mean you
differ with someone in religious
opinions or political opinions, you go
and shoot him in front of his children.
You can't do that. All right? And uh
also to make something very clear, I
don't know this guy. I mean people were
sending me some of his clips where he
said about Islam. So they sent me with
this clip which I'm going to respond to
and of course I'm not expecting to him
to respond back to me because he just
been killed. But his doubt and
misconception should be responded to.
Maybe his followers will watch our
videos and see this individual who is
very ignorant of Islam
and he had no clue about Islam.
The other thing I've heard he was pro
Zionist and justifying the genocide and
that is evil. No, no human being with a
sound intellect will try to justify what
the Zionists are doing to the people of
Gaza, killing children and women. Okay?
But yet that doesn't mean we should
justify what happened to him. Because
according to Islamic teaching even in a
Muslim country by Sharia if someone
insult the prophet
insult the prophet Muhammad or insult
Islam it is not for you and I to go and
carry out the law as
one of the great scholars of Islam that
lived 900 years ago mentioned. He said
there's consensus among the scholars.
It's not for anyone to carry out the
Islamic law or the Islamic legislation.
It is for the authority.
So to now the second point to respond to
his misinformation about Islam, he said
Islam is anguest or does not believe in
freedom of speech.
So we say there's nowhere in the world
believe or implement freedom of speech
without any restrictions.
So him said Islam does not believe in
freedom of speech completely. It's a lie
because in Islam there is freedom of
speech. However, it's based it is based
upon Sharia
the Sharia system. Okay. So uh for
example at the time of the prophetat
wasam and his companions and according
to Islamic legislation the Christians
are allowed likewise the Jewish people
are allowed to
say things which they believe in from
their religion. For example, the time of
the prophet wasallam when he was ruling
the Medina, Jewish people, they used to
say, "We don't believe you're a true
prophet. We are we believe you're a
false prophet." And there's not any
narration where the prophetat wasallam
ordered the companions to go and kill
Jewish people for believing he's not
true prophet or the Quran. It is not
from God. Likewise when the the his
companions his disciples were ruling per
Egypt or Palestine or Jordan where there
were many Christians and Jewish people.
So uh so Islam does give the right to
people to exercise and their freedom of
speech according to Islamic legislation.
Likewise in America. In America there's
no absolute freedom freedom of speech.
Likewise in Britain there's no absolute
freedom of speech. So every country
in the west or the east they implement
freedom of speech according to the law
mean they put restrictions to it. So uh
likewise when he said there's no freedom
of religion.
Okay. If he he meant by there's no
freedom of speech mean that in Islam you
can if you're a Muslim you cannot change
your religion then you have to be
consistent by not just this guy he
passed away but his followers who have
the same belief as him or same opinions
why no one speaks about what the Jewish
people believe the Juda law the mosaic
law according to Mosaic law if someone
changes religion or does not believe in
the god of the Israel or the Israelites,
you should be killed and it is for
everyone to implement the law. It is in
the Bible. Anyone can go and implement
the law. But according to Islamic
legislation, uh I always like to
emphasize in a Muslim country,
it is for the authority to implement the
law. All right? And also you mentioned
that Islam does not separate the mosque
from the state because Islam way of
life. Allah is not the only god of the
people in the mosque. Allah is the god
of everyone. The creator, the
legislator,
that's his creation.
And his legislation is based upon
justice. When humans legislate things,
there's evil desires involved.
Bias people are biased. They will
legislate something only for the poor
people, not for them. And other than
that and also let me make something uh
let me give you something which is very
important for the non-Muslims and
Islamic haters to hear. According to
Islamic legisl legislation, Sharia, the
Christians and Jewish people, they are
allowed to have their own courts in the
Islamic Sharia.
And I advise you to read the book by our
teacher and
sheh Abuyad
about the prophetat.
uh go check on his website
abuayadp prophet muhammmed.com
and you will uh there's the PDF there
inshallah tala may Allah guide those who
are sincere non-Muslims who are
sincerely seeking the truth to Islam